thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video citizens of the reject Nation we have
ourselves a trailer a trailer for something that
I honestly kind of forgot was coming out reason
being is because you know nowadays you're always
hearing about the constant spinoffs and things
that are being put into development from all
these franchises and IPS I usually just wait
to see if there's a trailer before I actually
believe it's coming out I've been so focused
on son the Hedgehog 3 that I haven't even put
much thought into the knuckles spin-off series
and I'm excited that we are actually going to
be getting this show we're of course watching
the trailer for Knuckles thank you to all who
let me know the trailer was out it's a Greg
solo today couldn't get a hold of my main
co-host John but either way I'm very much
excited for this inevitably excited too for the
breakdown from 3C films Chris who is an amazing
guy has an amazing YouTube channel I've learned
so much about Sonic via through him if you guys
are Sonic enthusiasts you guys should really
go watch his channel anyway you guys know what
to do leave a like on this video be very much
appreciated also tell me in the comments what
is your favorite part about this trailer who
are you hoping shows up in this series let's do
it you're an alien you're super powerful
recently saved the world with your friends
yes what you bad Vengeance classic I think more
like reading or or yoga so you're going to be a
Ser regular too hey Buddy isn't it great to
find oh [__] Sonic I am been a kid Warrior
yeah you arey I only remain on Earth because
I made a vow to you and the f I wonder how
is going to be here myself at home nope we are
not turning our living room into some kind of
gladiator fighting pit what is Ali doing
here he will be challenging his greatest
enemy it's a Negan is that our mailman this is
not a place of battle so I will begin my quest
oh [__] he's got the Hat think of a joke
I do not make jokes I make warriors let's
go get him so what's that guy's name Wade is he
without his little friends he's vulnerable he's
the key to our my newest creation is that the
you for Robotnik from Game of Thrones bring me
Knuckles oh [__] sorry this Lane is reserved you
think you can take my power like a bowling ball do
I look like I need your power what are you talking
about need power it's the whole reason we're
here oh that's cool man they got the uh they
got the actual OVA hat I made a promise to
protect this planet there's so many images
I am ready oh slap sh someone's about to get
slapped
fantastic whoa I think today
is going to be a beautiful
day that go down me you going to rescue him
no he must learn to rescue himself there
go Neo very neat oh man that looks really good
that looks like a really good time I got some
thoughts on that but before going into that do
want to thank today's video sponsor big thanks
to express VPN for sponsoring this video a real
game changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to work with
us it's an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and security but
there's more to it than that however there was
a very real incident recently with Spectrum
shutting down my internet and contacting me
due to a suspecting hacking attempt and funny
enough I realized I hadn't actually activated
my Express VPN on my new laptop that I got
a couple of months ago so I was paying the
consequences having faced a serious hacking issue
on YouTube a couple years ago that made expressvpn
my go-to for both security and freedom I mean
it and yes what you've heard is true believe
me this channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that are not
available in your country this means accessing
a vast rate of content of over a 100 countries
like a global Cinema your fingertips it's super
easy open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it whether it's
kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I player
YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered and
it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience
so if you want to get access to hundreds of
new shows use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn for
free that's expressvpn.com rejects so head
to expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again you know guys it is pretty crazy to see
how far we have come with the Sonic the Hedgehog
liveaction franchise because I still remember
like many of you when that first trailer came
out for Sonic the Hedgehog and everyone was so
upset by the design that they went back and redid
the design and the movie came out people really
liked it sequel came out I I like that one even
more than the first one Knuckles was the character
that we were all so excited for he was great in
it and this is a character that I do think would
make a really cool compelling lead character to
put it in a series format I think is a really
excellent call because you know with him being
the kid in a warrior that's another thing that
I really like about this Knuckles is is funny
and I thought the movie really captured that I
remember in the marketing for Sonic the Hedgehog
2 they didn't even really lean so much into the
comedy of Knuckles that just lean to the badassery
of the guy and then you watch the film and he is
funny into my understanding it's kind of like uh
it's kind of like how he is in the game you can
correct me if I'm wrong but my recollection of
of fan association with the character in please do
correct me if I'm wrong he did start off a little
bit more you know like I said badass and then as
time went on they kind of just lean more into the
comedic element of him throughout the games and
what's cool about this trailer is I feel like
you're going to get both you're not just going to
get the humor of Knuckles but you are also going
to get the true Aid a warrior side of him with
it being a show it also allows more opportunity
for more character development more character
depth and uh while I I do like the movies this
show will just give it more of an opportunity
to really uh flesh him out that much much more
flush out the world fles out the lore in a way
that you don't feel like you have to like rush
over to cuz you know like in in in a movie you
usually have like you got a quot of things you
you do got to hit you got to have an action scene
every you know this certain amount of minutes or
or something along that line you guys know how
movies work but with a series you get a little
bit more time to breathe and you I feel like you
can get more elements than just what you got from
the films while still giving you the elements that
you get from the films like there's so much about
this that reminded me of the movies via through
the human characters instead of getting you know
James Marson Who sonic you know pairs up with
you're GNA get Knuckles partner up with the Wade
guy which I not I remember I don't really remember
how I feel about wa I think he was all right not
like super excited about it he's not the reason
I'd be showing up for the series but he does seem
like he'd be the main human protagonist alongside
Knuckles here where he'd be I guess mentoring him
in some way or showing him the ways of the akid of
warrior uh which I feel like is a fun flip on on
Dynamics and what's really cool and and I still
am so wowed by this you know even though we're
we're in the day and age of like the Golden
Age of Television there's so many streaming
shows with just fantastic visual effects that
deserve to be seen on the big screen I'm still
of the mindset a lot of the time that whenever
you do a spin-off into a TV series that I feel
my my natural hesitation is that they're going to
dumb down the visual effects in some way or it's
going to feel lesser than looking at this trailer
the effects and the quality are still up to the
standards of watching a Sonic the Hedgehog movie
and speaking of Sonic the Hedgehog I imagine it
probably just being like the first episode you
know just to to get that out of the way that's
usually what you got to do is you instead of like
building up and wondering when Sonic's going to
come and you just kind of like feed that appetite
right away so you're not thinking about it the
rest of the show that being said I don't know who
else is going to show up in the series I like how
they just kept it pretty focused on Knuckles
the journey there and uh the Hound I don't know
the actor's name that didn't get CC what is that
guy's name but the I'm just going to pull up IMDb
really quick Rory mccan my God there's a whole
bunch of actors in This Carrie Elis is going
to appear Christopher Lloyd's gonna be in here
kid Cy Eddie Patterson my God you see you do see
Paul Shear in the trailer okay so there's no Jim
Carrey listed here but he is confirmed to return
for Sonic 3 and I I don't know if how much this
is going to tie into Sonic 3 like is this going
to be necessary viewing are they going to build
out the Cinematic Universe of Sonic the Hedgehog
to that degree where I I watch Sonic 3 and if I
didn't watch the series am I going to feel like
left out or are they going to do that Marvel
thing where they recap just like a couple of
sentences that are required for me to understand
the Journey of Knuckles returning are they going
to set up shadow in some way in this series just
slowing down this trailer I'm loving the designs
of all the meca suits and then I'm trying to find
this one character here here that it popped up for
a brief SEC who is this guy can you guys tell me
in the comments below is this supposed to be like
knuckles's Dad or something cuz it kind of looks
like it looks like they could be related and I
guess the last thing is you know one thing with
with characters um you know you got tals here and
then you know at the end of Sonic the Hedgehog
to you see the evolution of Sonic's powers and
I'm wondering how much of an evolution we going
to get and and knuckles's powers or if we'll
we'll see an evolution and power set you know
you got tales in the trailer as well if we'll
see an evolution there like what are the upgrades
going to be ultimately what will the the character
Arc be for the guy because you know Knuckles does
have a character Arc in the in the second movie so
I'm wondering what the specific journey is cuz
they it feels like really like clearly defined
for Sonic in the in the first two movies while
I I'm looking forward to the uh potential for
better exploration for this character at the
same time I am going all right what is going
to be the specific Journey this guy's going to be
be going on and I mean I just watched the trailer
one time I should just watch it again and maybe
I'll be like I know what that answer is but you
guys tell me in the comments you guys are smarter
than me leave it in the comments Below guys what
did you think about this trailer I thought it was
more than satisfactory it's a pretty cool trailer
man it's pretty sweet leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe uh leave a like uh
we got more trailers I'm sure to cover coming
out of Super Bowl talk to youall [Music] soon